(Audience cheering)
Okay. We've been drinking a little bit for the whole time.
Hey, can I ask you by the way, where can I get your wine?
We're in like grocery stores all across the country.
yay!
Yes you can get it, you can walk down your grocery aisle.
Can I say that you can go to drink avaline.com.
Of course
and we have a bottle locator on our site.
You just put in your zip code.
We'll tell you where the local,
the closest bottle of Valine is to you.
We're just there you guys!
We're just waiting for you to enjoy.
And if you go to the drewbarrymoreshow.com,
we're going to show you right how to get over to the Avaline
site and get your glass and get a drink in.
All right now, It's almost time to go,
but we love to leave you with a little
something to take on the road.
It's a tradition for us,
and it's called the doggy bag.
(Dazzling music)
(Dog Barks)
And today it's an LA institution,
denim doctors on Beverly Boulevard.
They can make your favorite jeans last forever.
They do alterations and repairs,
and they can even turn your favorite jeans into maternity
jeans with elastic bands. And you don't have to be in LA.
You can send your jeans to the denim doctors
from wherever you are. So take a look.
So you know, this is goodbye.
And I just want to thank you so much.
Auntie poo poo, otherwise known as Cameron Diaz,
to everyone else on the planet, but.
Thanks, poops.
Love you.